not looking good at this point ladies
and gentlemen it appears the Republican
healthcare plan is going to die on the
floor of the house coincidentally dying
on the floor of the house happens to be
the Republican health care plan that's
actually how it works oh yeah just die
on the house and they're fine convenient
in May just announced president Trump's
gonna give the commencement address at a
Christian University Trump speech will
be entitled if Jesus is so great why
does he have a Mexican name what's going
on even watching the Supreme Court
nominees it's incredible today's Supreme
Court nominee Neil Gorsuch was grilled
about his stance on torture yeah and
after just five minutes of questioning
of course it's broke down told him
everything that's all that deserved
you know you gave it the perfect amount
you gave it just what it was owed
according to a note poll I found this
strange according to a new poll Muslims
are the religious group most satisfied
with life in America yet when asked why
Muslims said that travel ban totally
kept our in-laws from visiting so this
is kind of cool I read that this Amazon
Prime Amazon Prime has made it possible
to have beer and wine delivered to your
home
by Alexa
all you have to do is say the phrase
Alexa daddy's sad you believe that we're
gonna get beer and wine delivered to our
houses whenever we want it no that's
fantastic laying around in your
underwear I want beer on a drone hey
check this out crazy story there's a new
trend across the country of penis rings
yes penis ring penis rings
shut up not jewelry gangs of penises
that get together to commit crime
hey fellas here's the plan
you got it get in we get out in five
minutes wait a minute I could be taking
two ways be satisfied with two minutes
Hey
you